WE DID NOT HAVE STANDING.
WE TRIED TO EXPLAIN THAT TO THE
PRESIDENT ON NUMEROUS
OCCASIONS.
>> LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT ANOTHER
ONE OF YOUR NOTES.
YOU NOTED THAT MR. ROSEN SAID
TO MR. TRUMP "DOJ CAN AND WILL
SNAP ITS FINGERS AND CHANGE THE
OUTCOME OF THE ELECTION.
THIS QUOTE HOW DID THE PRESENT
RESPOND TO THAT?
>> YOU RESPONDED QUICKLY AND
SAID ESSENTIALLY THAT IS NOT
WHAT I'M ASKING YOU TO DO.
I'M ASKING YOU TO SAY IT WAS
CROPPED AND LEAVE IT TO ME AND
THE REPUBLICAN CONGRESS.
>> LET'S NOT -- AS YOU'RE
SPEAKING TO THAT, THE PRESIDENT
SAID JUST SAY THE ELECTION WAS
CROPPED AND LEAVE THE REST TO
ME AND REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN.
MR. DONAHUE, THAT'S DIRECT
QUOTE FROM PRESIDENT TRUMP,
CORRECT?
TWO THAT'S AN EXACT QUOTE FROM
THE PRESIDENT. YES.
>> THE NEXT NOTE SHOWS EVEN
THAT THE PRESIDENT PRESSING.
EVEN THOUGH HE WAS TOLD THERE
IS NO EVIDENCE OF FRAUD, THE
PRESIDENT KEEPS SAYING THE
DEPARTMENT WAS "OBLIGATED TO
TELL PEOPLE THAT THIS WAS AN
ILLEGAL, CORRUPT ELECTION."
>> THAT IS ALSO AN EXACT QUOTE
FROM THE PRESIDENT.
YES.
>> LET ME BE CLEAR.
DID THE DEPARTMENT FIND ANY
EVIDENCE TO CONCLUDE THERE IS
ANYTHING ILLEGAL OR CORRUPT
ABOUT THE 2020 ELECTION?
>> THERE WERE ISOLATED
INSTANCES OF FRAUD, NONE OF
THEM CAME CLOSE TO CALLING INTO
QUESTION THE OUTCOME OF THE
ELECTION IN ANY INDIVIDUAL
STATE.
>> HOW WOULD YOU DESCRIBE THE
PRESIDENT'S GOOD DEMEANOR?
TWO HE WAS MORE AGITATED THAN
HE WAS ON DECEMBER 15th.
THE PRESIDENT, THROUGHOUT THESE
MEETINGS AND PHONE CONVERSATIONS
, WAS ADAMANT HE HAD WON AND WE
ARE NOT DOING OUR JOB.
BUT, IT'D ESCALATE OVER TIME
UNTIL ULTIMATELY THE MEETING ON
JANUARY 3rd WHICH WAS THE MOST
EXTREME OF THE MEETINGS AND
CONVERSATIONS.
>> I WANT TO MAKE SURE WE DON'T
GLOSSES OVER.
JUST SAY IT WAS CROPPED AND
LEAVE THE REST TO US. THE
PRESIDENT ONE OF THE TOP
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT OFFICIALS TO
DECLARE THE ELECTION WAS
CROPPED EVEN THOUGH AS A NEW,
IT WAS ABSOLUTELY NO EVIDENCE
TO SUPPORT THAT STATEMENT.